people from around the world like to
visit European Christmas markets and get
into the holiday spirit with the help of
mulled wine gingerbread or candied
almonds all the Christmas spirit and all
the lights and everybody's just together
everybody being good well and the
markets have a centuries-old tradition
in Germany each year some 270 million
people visit the country's 2,500
Christmas markets at Berlin's museum of
European cultures jana had lain research
as the roots of the tradition
there were always weekly farmers markets
and then they were simply extended
during the Christmas season that impulse
came especially from the merchants and
showman who earned their livings with
the markets
markets have been held in the run-up to
Christmas since the late Middle Ages in
the 14th century craftsmen were allowed
to set up stalls selling small gifts for
children distance leaflet market is one
of germany's oldest christmas markets
dating back to 14th or in nuremberg the
question does marked dates back to the
mid 16th century it's opened every year
by the Christ child account there's all
the Commons I'm Christmas markets
continue to be big commercial draws for
visitors from around the world the
modern celebration of Christmas owes
much to German traditions which have
been exported for and wide the British
city of Birmingham is home to the
largest German Christmas market outside
Germany but they all have one thing in
common they're all places where lots of
people need in order to prepare for a
pleasant lovely time in this case with
the Christmas market it's preparing to
mark the birth of Christ but there's
long been a secularization where the
religious roots of the tradition no
longer play a major role in China and
China volumio field what's clear is that
an our increasingly individualistic era
people have a growing need for communal
experiences a Christmas market is a
perfect place for that with its holiday
cheer and familiar scents from childhood